todo mundo já teve alguma dificuldade na
escola
eu por exemplo tenho dificuldade em
exarhia urbanos também né
às vezes as dificuldades ficam
complicadas de resolver a questão nos
pedem interesse no próprio texto da lei
diz aquela matéria fica uma coisa chata
que está ali só para fazer diz reprovar
na escola
além disso a gente sabe que
historicamente essas relações entre o
professor o aluno sempre foram muito
verticais o aluno vê o professor como
detentor do conhecimento e ele sente que
a única função dele lá é absorver tudo
que jogando em cima dele
sim existem movimentos recentes
especialmente por meio da tecnologia que
buscam novas formas de fazer o aluno
aprender mas não é disso que a gente vai
falar hoje que a gente veio falar é de
colocar o único protagonista e produtor
do próprio conhecimento eu pedro demos
conta desses problemas no começo de 2015
a gente começou a procurar soluções para
ajudar nossos colegas
a gente quis aproveitar melhor as
habilidades de cada um engraçado aqui
sempre teve jeito para estudar sempre
foi bom nas matérias da escola e sempre
gostou de ajudar os colegas
já o joão sempre adorou a produção de
vídeos e tem um jeito para empreender
ligando a kombi a gente chegou a uma
conclusão
vamos criar um canal de vídeo aulas
conheçam o pedro ensina como destino
eles vão trabalhar
boa sorte
a gente começou procurando as dúvidas
mais comuns dos nossos amigos dentro da
sala mesmo e aí com uma câmera na mão e
um pouco de cartolina a gente começou a
trabalhar no começo não foi tudo mil
maravilhas a gente teve dificuldade para
gravar o áudio depois de acertar onde a
colocar a matéria a gente vai fazendo e
trabalhando a gente comprou uma lousa e
chegou num formato que a gente tem hoje
o que a gente não tinha parado para
pensar no impacto que tudo isso ia
causar sim a gente começou a receber
elogios dos nossos amigos para que a
gente recomenda as vídeo-aulas dos
nossos professores incentivando mas foi
questão de semanas pra gente começar a
receber dentro do próprio youtube
mensagens de pessoas que a gente nunca
tinha conhecido o primeiro de outras
escolas
depois de três cidades e até de estados
o pai do ensino em pouco tempo alcançou
o brasil inteiro hoje a gente já tem
mais de mil inscritos e nós mais famoso
tem 15 mil visualizações
é interessante pensar que a gente vai
pra escola acaba domingo na aula
só que 15 mil pessoas foram preto e
assistir aula de filosofia
muitas delas inclusive recomendadas
pelos próprios professores
o diferencial do pedro ensina é
exatamente isso nós somos alunos normais
explicando para outros alunos
é uma relação horizontal é quase que uma
conversa entre colegas e é isso que a
gente quer dizer colocar o aluno com o
protagonista
sim é esse segredo a mensagem que a
gente quer passar para vocês hoje o
aluno tem que estar no centro ele é o
cara que produz ele é o cara que
dissemina por seus amigos porque se
perguntam explicar a primeira coisa
aluno adoro aprender com o aluno é
inevitável a relação que nós temos com
os outros tende a ser com maior
afinidade do que aquela que a gente tem
os professores mesmo que o professor
seja muito bom a gente se sente mais
confortável para tirar dúvidas uns com
os outros
a gente tem se sente mais confortável
para admitir que nós não estamos
entendendo o pedaço da matéria e
principalmente para cooperar porque
nessa relação entre alunos não existe a
idéia de um que sabe passando por que
não entendeu nada pelo contrário eu
posso ajudar você com uma aula de física
você me retribuir essa ajuda me
explicando logo de biologia por exemplo
isso a gente percebeu dentre as vídeo
aulas porque boa parte das mensagens que
a gente recebia era mais ou menos assim
meu obrigado
do jeito que você explica eu consigo
entender o negócio que nunca tinha
entendido nas aulas convencionais
esse clima entre os alunos é muito
importante ajuda muito na hora de
aprender a gente é bobo a gente brinca
as mais importante a gente sabe quais
são as do
os mais cruéis do que elas são nossas
também outro ponto importante é que quem
produz se interessa
o aluno que vai atrás de novo jeito de
explicar pra entender a matéria para
ajudar os amigos
ele enfrenta naturalmente o desafio
desse ativo isso ajudar muito na hora de
aprender a gente sentiu isso fazendo as
vídeo aulas
você acha que o pt sabe tudo o que eu
aprendi nada de exatas nem de humanas
fazendo essas vídeo aulas e editando e
último lugar esse interesse gera mais
interesse
eu não preciso que 100% dos alunos
estejam interessados têm esse dom para
ensinar
eu só preciso que quem tem essa vontade
essa vocação ou essa vontade e faça isso
com interesse porque esse cara que foi
atrás de novas formas de aprender e de
ensinar ele vai se entusiasma
eu acho que muitos de vocês já ouviram
já perceberam que o melhor professor é
aquele que está engajado que está
interessado naquilo que ele está
ensinando multiplica isso para quando um
aluno explicando para outro aluno o que
acontece na cabeça de quem está
assistindo é quase inconsciente o outro
não vai pensar para aí se esse cara que
é um nome que nem eu não tem nada de
diferente ele está se esforçando tanto
para passar esse conhecimento para mim
ele está tão interessado será que essa
matéria tão chato quanto achava que era
antes
aos poucos esse mundo do jeito que esse
cara tem de ver aquela matéria de
estudar aquela matéria estudar
matemática português pode não ser mais
tão chato para antes claro isso é uma
possibilidade não são sempre cento dos
casos que vão ser assim que forem bons e
graduais mas eu acho que é uma
possibilidade que vale a pena investir e
que a gente quer que vocês tinham de
tudo isso o mais importante para um
futuro melhor educação é colocar o aluno
como ativo
assim elas são um bom exemplo disso e
elas não são tão complicada de fazer
mais uma escola que a do espaço
precisamos lutar nos ajudarem serem
ajudados fazem uma grande diferença
o mais importante é perder essa
mentalidade de colônia desinteressados
por padrão que ele não gosta da escola
que ele acha chato que ele só vai porque
ele é obrigado
é importante também a gente criar um
ambiente que estimula esse protagonismo
o professor não sai de cena muito pelo
contrário ele pode por exemplo
identificar quais os seus alunos têm
essa vocação esse jeito está a passar-se
o próprio ao conhecimento que eles têm
para seus amigos
a partir disso ele estimula esses caras
por exemplo orientando sobre quais são
as fontes confiáveis para buscar
conteúdo dando idéias sobre como eles
podem passar esse conhecimento com os
amigos
a maneira mais eficiente tudo isso é
muito importante
e voltando para as vídeo-aulas o
conteúdo sem dúvida essencial é o cordel
negócio mas o estilo também é super
importante é o que gera esse clima de
interação entre alunos é o que faz é
diferente
o pd ensina por exemplo sempre termina
de um jeito diferente
essa é toda a gente que algumas vídeo
aulas também é bom a gente sabe que
discutir o futuro da educação aquela
complicado e delicado mas a gente tem
certeza de que a partir de agora pra
fazer grandes mudanças na educação a
gente precisa botar o aluno no centro
ele é o cara que faz ele é o cara que
passa por seus amigos
essa é uma tarefa a gente precisa de
tempo e motivação
mas quem melhor para decidir o futuro da
educação do que quem participa dela
agora
essa foi a banda perdeu o hábito valeu
jogador ligado